I think it's funny in that there's
definitely a huge difference between how
you just explained design in from a
market perspective and how you would
explain design as the curator at Moma in
my world.
Design really is about beauty.
It's about
how does this work fit in with my
collection?
How does this look next to everything
else in my collection?
It really has nothing to do with the old
form versus function debate.
Um,
ornament can still be crime in the,
in the,
in the contemporary design movement.
But the work itself is frequently an
ornament.
It's not about a work having ornament
applied to it.
It's about the work itself,
mimicking sculpture,
mimicking contemporary art,
and that is the fundamental basis of
contemporary design in the market world.
On the other side of the coin,
if I was to become a full on curator at
an institution,
I would be far more concerned with good
design that question,
what is good design and,
and,
and form and function.
And thus one of my heroes,
one of my personal heroes over the last
20 years in terms of who is the most
innovative,
smartest designer of our times,
to which I would say Jasper Morrison,
Morrison is not much of a presence in
the market because everything he does is
so minimalist and so oriented towards
function.
Making this piece work.
You steps.